just two days big brother all-stars
premieres on cbs and we've got exclusive
details on how in the world they're
going to pull it off from host julie
chen moonves
i'm doing testing i'm doing testing
again and then i'm going to do more
testing be
farther than ever from the house guests
as they get evicted
no hugs not even a chenbai handshake
there's too much on the line to not go
above and beyond
the protocol to make sure everyone is
safe
a few of the new rules no live audience
julie won't be able to visit the house
and
all those groceries delivered to the
house guests must be disinfected
will folks be tested once they're in the
house each house guests as we speak
right now they're quarantined by
themselves homes that we've rented for
them
they're getting tested every few days
they will go in once they've been clean
and clear for at least 14 days and then
even once they get in the house
they're still going to be tested they
have no contact with
anyone that includes the crew working
behind the scenes
everyone is working in a pod and those
pods basically stay together and don't
cross mingle with any of the other pods
no one is living on the compound so
people are going home at the end of
their shift we produce this behind the
walls they only hear our voices
they don't really see us throughout
their stay in the big brother
in the living house this season the
house is modeled to look like a loft and
only e.t can show you an exclusive look
of the upstairs lounge and the head of
household bedroom
on premiere night the house guests will
move in on live tv
something that's never happened before
once they go in there they are going to
be just like
any other big brother cast so yeah
hookups are allowed
contestants can share a bed and the
challenges
are happening
if you ask me once you're in the big
brother house
it might be one of the safest places to
[Music]
be